You would think with all those furry-hatted
guards wandering around, a team of 24-hour
security personnel and her own private police
force, whose cars are uniquely painted red
by the way, and let us not forget her very
own guard corgis.
That it would be rather difficult to break
into the home of the world’s largest landowner
and head-of-state of 16 countries.
Surely only a highly trained secret agent
could accomplish such a feat.
No, this drunken fellow managed it, without
any prior planning, not once, but twice.
This paragon of plundering is London-born
Michael Fagan.
Ironically he is the son of a champion safe
breaker, but that wasn’t what persuaded
him to try his hands at unlawfully entering
Buckingham Palace.
In interviews he stated he had no motive and
had never even considered the break-in before,
he had simply gotten drunk at a local pub
and was walking home past the palace at 7am
when he decided to go for a stroll through
the halls of, possibly the world’s most
famous residence.
Unemployed painter & decorator Michael Fagan
made he grand break-in on July 9th 1982 when
he was 33-years-old.
After leaving the pub, the spritely drunk
managed to scale a 14-foot-high wall at the
rear of Buckingham Palace’s perimeter.
A wall topped with barbed wire and revolving
spikes nonetheless.
I struggle to climb into bed at 7am after
a night in the pub, so Fagan must have really,
really wanted to get a glimpse of Queenie
to clamber over that.
He then shimmied his way up a drainpipe on
the rear of the palace and entered through
an unlocked window.
Fagan then spent a whole 15 minutes wandering
the halls of the palace without being seen.
One member of the palace’s domestic staff
recalls seeing him but afterwards she said
she didn’t think he was “sufficiently
suspicious” enough to raise an alarm.
So presumably one would have to be “outrageously
suspicious” before the staff would actually
do anything.
According to Fagan, after aimlessly wandering
the halls he found his way to the royal apartments
by “following the pictures” on the walls.
Not really sure what he means by that, but
I can only imagine there are an increasing
number of photos of corgis on the walls as
you close in on the royal apartments.
First he entered Charles’ room but he was
not there, Fagan found half a bottle of white
wine of the shelf which he drunk.
In an interview Fagan later noted that the
wine was “really cheap”.
Fagan then snuck into the Queen’s bedroom
where he found Her Majesty asleep.
Fagan later noted that the bed was large but
she was definitely sleeping alone.
He ripped the curtains open and she immediately
awoke.
She sounded her night alarm for help, but
the maid in the next room was vacuuming, so
neither she nor anyone else on duty heard
the Queen’s distress call.
So what did Her Majesty do next, well call
the police of course.
I’d just love to be to be the 999 operator
taking a call from the Queen.
Well she didn’t actually call the police,
she called the palace telephonist who called
the police for her.
So what did Fagan and Her Majesty the Queen
get up to for several awkward minutes whilst
she was waiting for the police to arrive?
Well she, along with a footman, actually lured
Fagan into the pantry with the promise of
free cigarettes and a glass of whiskey.
The Queen and her footman kept Fagan busy
in the pantry with cigarettes and whiskey
until the police came and he was arrested.
So what was Fagan’s punishment for his dastardly
royal intrusion?
A lengthy jail sentence?
Was he set upon by a pack of ravenous corgis?
Nope, he got away completely scot-free.
Surprisingly, at that time there were no special
laws in place that meant breaking into Buckingham
Palace was a serious crime, beyond normal
trespassing.
Fagan was let go without any charge because
under UK law trespassing is not a criminal
offence but a civil wrong.
The Queen could have taken him to court for
damages, if she wanted to, but can you really
imagine the Queen in court?
She’s far too busy deciding whether she
would like her morning omelette made out of
quail eggs or duck eggs.
The Queen is also exempt from having to legally
provide evidence, unlike us meagre peasants.
Fagan was however charged for stealing the
bottle of wine, since that’s the only thing
they had on him, so why the hell not?
But the theft charge was dropped because the
judge concluded that Fagan was not mentally
stable and admitted him to spend six months
in a psychiatric hospital.
It wasn’t until 2007 when a new law was
introduced in the UK which made trespassing
on royal or government-owned property a criminal
offence.
But this wasn’t Fagan’s first expedition
inside the Palace, he actually broke in a
month earlier too.
During his first visit he didn’t meet the
Queen but he spent 10 minutes wandering the
palace’s vast hallways, staring at paintings.
He then found his way to the throne room and
sat on the throne for a bit before leaving
the palace, completely undetected.
But these two Michael Fagan incidents aren’t
the first times that Her Majesty’s private
quarters have been penetrated.
In 2013 a burglar broke into the palace after
scaling a wall and kicking a door down, he
made his was deep into the palace but was
swiftly arrested.
Also, in 1981 three German tourists camped
in the grounds of Buckingham Palace the entire
night, mistaking it for Hyde Park.
Philip, I think there’s some Germans in
our garden, off with their Hans!
…I mean heads.